الى من نشاط التواصل وقضيه شغلتها في
الساعات الماضيه تحت واسمي خلو الذهب او
رفعوا سعرها وجرام الذهب تفعل رواد من
السطر التواصل في مصر وعبروا عن غضبهم
والسيائهم وسخريتهم من ارتفاع سعر جرام
الذهب في الاسواق المصريه لاسعار وصفوها
بالجنونيه وغير المسبوقه حيث بلغ سعره
جرام الذهب الواحد من عيار
21,800 جنيه مصري ما يعادل 25
اذا سجلت اسعار الذهب من عيار 21 في مصر
زياده بحوالي 600 جنيه خلال اسبوعين فقط
ماذا فعلت التداول لوقف نشر اسعارها لكن
ما هي اسباب ارتفاع سعر الذهب ارجع
مسؤولون بالشعبه العمل المصريه للذهب ما
يحدث الى تعويم جنيه وتغيير سعر صرفه امام
الدولار وكيلو سابق لوزاره الاقتصاد
والتجاره الخارجيه قال ان تجاره الذهب
يقدرون الدولار حاليا بنحو 34 جنيها كما
قال عضو في شعبه المشغولات الذهبيه انه
هناك تداعبا تحت ما وصفها باوهام الارض
والطلبه ان هناك تفوت في الاسعار بالسوق
فعلا
المحليه عن السعر العالميه
واغلب على تفاعل المصريين مع قضيه ارتفاع
سعر الذهب التندر والاستياء والمقارنه
سوزان كتبت على تويتر يحيى الفخراني في
فيلم الكيف كان يقبض 250 جنيه وفي نفس
الفيلم في واحد بيقول له جرام الذهب ب 12
جنيه يعني يقبض 21 جرام ذهب يعني
3200 او سناء او
32,550 جنيه بسعر النهارده لا وما كانوش
كان فينه رحل الشمال دلوقتي
اما طارق تيتو فكتب انت متخيل انه مرتبك
بقى مرتين جرام ذهب من غير المصنعيه اثنين
جرام